- I got myself some cool
little platform Vans.
- [Interviewer] Yes, I see that,
you're three inches taller now.
(Ronnie laughs)
All right, Ronnie.
Ronnie, welcome back to LA.
- Thank you (laughing)
- [Interviewer] So last
time we spoke was what?
Probably last fall, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] That
was before Thanksgiving?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And
what's gone on since then?
'Cause you were leaving
just a couple of days
after I had spoke to you.
- So what's been going on since then.
I left after, the day after Thanksgiving
is when I got back to Texas.
- [Interviewer] Your family is there?
- Yes, my family picked me up
and I was staying with a
family friend for a little bit.
See, it took about...
I got on methadone on December 9th,
and I've been on methadone before.
It's kinda one of those
things I was on and off doing.
And I got back on it
and from then I was just continuing
to try and get into rehab
and I think it was just
a little bit difficult
because of the seasons.
And when I called, I told
my methadone counselor
that I was trying to get into
this place called Nexus Recovery,
the one I had been in when I was pregnant.
And it devastated me because they told me
that I wasn't gonna be able
to get into the program
and I just...
I remember that feeling
of just feeling like,
"Damn, I'm not gonna be able to go in."
- [Interviewer] You couldn't get in why?
- Just because the last time,
the program I wanted to be in was PBWC,
which was parenting women
and women with children
and pregnant women.
And that program--
- [Interviewer] 'Cause your
son is one year old now?
- Yes, he's one years old now.
The last time I had been in that program,
I was nine months pregnant.
The year before I had gotten
out, December 15th, of 2018
I had my son January 13th, of 2019.
And when I called,
they told me that I wasn't
gonna be able to get in
for the simple fact that I
don't have custody of my child
and I'm not pregnant.
And the program that they
wanted me to be in was AW,
which is adult women.
And that program is two weeks.
That's not enough time,
that is enough time for me to get healthy
and go back out on a run,
is what I look at it as.
It's just ridiculous.
- [Interviewer] And you've been to rehab,
how many times now?
- This was gonna be my,
what was 16th, 16th or 17th.
Yeah, this is my, I've lost count.
I know it was either 16th or my 17th time.
And goodness gracious,
so many rehabs, right?
Rehabs, detoxes, all of that.
Wait, hold on.
What does it mean?
I'm not gonna go back
and recount all of them,
whatever, the last video
was, it's one more than that.
- [Interviewer] A dozen so or so.
- So after that, I remember going home
from the methadone clinic and
just crying to my mom like,
"They're not gonna take me,
"and I really need this
program, I really need it."
And my mom,
I just asked her, "Will you pray with me?"
and I'm kinda not really the
most religious person ever,
but I remember asking her to pray with me
and we prayed right before
she dropped me back off.
And the next day when she went
to help to pick me up to
go back to the clinic,
she was telling me,
not to be too down about it,
that there's just other rehabs,
just give it a second,
just give some time.
And I remember when I went to
the methadone clinic that day,
my counselor told me, "Hey, all right,
"are you gonna be ready December 23rd?"
And I said, "December 23rd, for what?"
And he said, "They're gonna
admit you to the PBWC program".
So I ended up getting the program I wanted
and I ended up committing the first day
to do the 90 days instead of just the 30.
And when I got there,
I remember,
it was kind of a little
struggle getting admitted
and I started to get
really anxious about it
and I was having like really bad anxiety.
I was gonna have a panic,
I felt like I was gonna
have a panic attack
on the way over there.
In the car, it was just me and my dad.
And I was just like (humming)
I just felt like the
tightness in my chest,
it was just so, it hurt almost.
- [Interviewer] And what
was that anxiety about?
- Just going to rehab.
- [Interviewer] I mean just
how difficult it was gonna be
to stop heroin?
- Yeah, it was the thought of
like, "I know I can do this."
I've been off heroin before,
I've been clean.
I know it was only only six months,
but to me that was a lot,
because I've never tried before.
And I just, I knew I could do it.
I knew I had it in me,
but I was afraid that I was gonna fail.
So after I got dropped
off, that was on the 23rd.
The next few weeks of me being
in rehab was really difficult for me
because I think I had
been too hard on myself,
I was just like,
I was so terrified of messing up again
and relapsing that I wasn't giving myself
the opportunity to really try, to excel,
to ask for help, to be happy.
So, I spent a lot of
my time in rehab alone
in my room crying.
I was at a point where I just felt so low.
I felt like I had no strength
to get myself back up.
Or maybe it was just the fact
that I didn't wanna get back up.
Do you remember me telling
you in the last video
about the kidnapping?
And I had been struggling really hard
with PTSD at this point.
And I'm talking like
there's a specific pair
of flip flops that I would see,
that this girl had and it
was the exact same flip flops
that I had wore here,
when I had first became homeless
and they had picked me up
and took me to the hotel.
It was that same pair of sandals.
I went haywire.
My brain went into that
fight or flight mode,
like, "I have to get out of here,
"I have to get out of here,
I have to get out of here."
Like, "They're coming, someone's watching,
"they're gonna get me."
And this is a 100% sober,
'cause of course I'm in rehab
and I was constantly
checking the shower curtains
to see if somebody was behind them,
checking under my bed
before I went to sleep.
I would go as far as
looking down the crack
between the wall and my
mattress at nighttime,
because of how afraid I was.
And that was costing a
lot of energy for me.
It was draining me completely.
And that went on for the
whole time I was in rehab.
Unsurprisingly, I was
being bullied at rehab.
I'm a 22 year old being bullied
by 30 and 40 year old women.
And it hurt because it
was my first day of rehab,
the first day I got there,
everybody was just hating on me.
Nobody wanted to talk to me
and I was tryna talk to
people and it didn't work out.
People were just constantly hating on me,
I could hear them talking about me,
like you don't even know me,
I've been here for for a
couple of weeks now, two weeks,
you've never once to talk to me.
You don't even know my name.
My first, my middle,
my first name, my middle
name or my last name,
but you hate me so much and I'm just,
I'm nasty, I'm disgusting,
I'm a whore because...
What?
Because the guy that you
think is super-duper hot
that is in narcotics anonymous
says hello to me every single day
because I know them from the
previous years I was here.
And it was just little things like that,
that they just hated on me for.
So, I had no friends in rehab.
And I think that also fueled my PTSD,
with everybody knowing each other
and me not knowing any of them,
I felt like they were
just coming against me.
And like I said,
I got and have been into
rehab the 23rd of December
and I was kicked out of rehab
on the 7th of January, I believe,
no, it was the 21st,
I was there like, not even a month,
a little less than a month.
I was kicked out of rehab.
I remember like,
I was just bawling my eyes out
because what had happened was
this girl, these two women,
they were like 40 years old,
they've got children
and they had cliqued up
and one day one of the girls,
it was midnight and she woke up
and she wanted to get a snack
and the tech was like, "Cool,
just come to the closet."
So I decided, "Oh cool, can
I have a snack as well."
So I went in there and I got some Oreos
and the very next
morning, which was Sunday,
that same girl that we had
gotten cookies together
at the same time, looked at me and said,
"Don't ever try and get...
"don't ever try and mess
up what I got going on
"when I'm going to get snacks".
And I looked at her and I said,
"We're all allowed to get snacks,
"it's not like I took what you wanted,
"you went in front of me"
and the way, she did
it, she tried to do it
in front of everybody.
It's Sunday morning, we're
all getting ready for church
and we're in the butt hut,
which is where we have
to smoke our cigarettes.
And she says it in front of everybody.
And I look at her and I tried
to be respectful and say,
"Well, anybody can get cookies,
"it's not, Miss Lisa, which
was the tech is really cool.
"You should not bothered by that."
And what did she say?
The girl looked at me and she said,
"I told you not to do it."
And I looked at her and I said,
"I'm allowed to get
snacks when I want to."
I said, "You're not gonna sit here
"and bully me over some Oreos."
Everybody was just kinda looking around,
I guess she thought that I
wasn't gonna stand up for myself.
And she was just yelling like,
"I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to you,
"but when I tell you
something, you better listen
"because," I guess she
tried to, what'd she say?
"You better listen because I'm
old enough to be your mama".
And I looked at her and I
said, "Well, you're not my mama
"and you're not gonna tell me what to do".
And she made this ugly face at me,
She was like (grumbling)
so I just looked at her and
I went (grumbling) back,
just not good,
because that type of stuff
is not my nature either,
but when you're gonna sit here
and just try and pasture me,
and that wasn't the only
time she had done it.
Her and her little friend had tried
to do it multiple times
over, just anything,
anything, I couldn't even
sneeze, if she sneezed before me,
like I couldn't speak in class
without them trying to make some noise
and make me feel like I was less then,
I remember in class I said,
"Oh, I used to not believe in Jesus".
And she said,
(snickering)
"Oh my God", like her,
they were both snickering and stuff.
And I was just like, "what?"
So this had been on for the whole time
that I was there in rehab.
And the reason I got
kicked out was because,
one of the girls,
we were in a narcotics anonymous meeting
and you're only allowed to
sit in the first five rows
and there's 31 girls and five rows.
So, I set three rows and four seats over
from one of those girls,
one of the mean ones.
And she says, "I can't see.",
and I don't know who she's talking to,
so I just keep on, and she was
like, "Hello, I can't see".
And I'm sitting, I turned around,
and she's all the way back
there, I'm all the way up here.
She's on the fifth row, I'm on the third.
I'm on the...
Yeah, I'm on the second
'cause I sat three in front of her.
And she started yelling and
she got up, got in my face,
started cursing at me specifically said,
"You're not gonna be here long".
Walked up, got her baby and left.
And then the program director, he's...
Like when we're in the
auditorium, there's two doors.
His office is right on the other side
of this left-hand door.
And I hear her crying,
saying that I'm bullying her
and I'm being mean to
her, and within two hours
after that happening, he
pulls me aside and he says,
"You need to pack your belongings."
And they were gonna drop
me off on a street corner
with all of my stuff.
They said, "We can't do anything for you,
"we can't help you get..."
And I said, "Well, if
you're gonna kick me out,
"you can't give me like a
couple of days to figure out
"where to live?"
I was supposed to live at
this rehab for 90 days,
I made it 21.
It was unfair because
he did no investigating,
no talking to other people in class
to see what had really happened,
'cause if he would've, he would've known
that everybody saw that she
got up and got in my face,
but I was a problem.
So I ended up getting kicked out
and I called my mom and
she was really upset
because she thought that
I had done something
and I told her, "Mom,
I didn't do anything.
"They are bullying me."
And my mom had known
when I had been in that exact same rehab
when I was pregnant, I
was bullied a lot as well.
I get bullied a lot of places that I go,
out here on the streets.
You wouldn't imagine how bad I get it.
I can walk by a female's tent,
a female in her boyfriend's tent
to go to that store
right there to get a soda
and walk back in that same
direction right in front of her,
and the she will straight
up get out of her tent
and start yelling at me and tell me,
she's gonna beat me up if
I don't get moving along.
And I'm looking at her like,
"I don't know who you are.
"I don't, who are you?
"I'm going to get a drink."
- [Interviewer] It's good that
you stand up for yourself.
- Yeah, and I'm just like,
it's just ridiculous the way
that people act sometimes.
And, so I remember when my mom was like,
"That makes no sense, why wouldn't he talk
"to other people in class?
"Why wouldn't he do
this and this and that?"
And I said, "Mama, you know what?
"I don't know".
When I really thought about
it, I think the reason
why they kicked me out instead of her
was because she had her
newborn child with her.
But that's still unfair.
I should not have gotten
kicked out like that.
They should have found her
another program to go to.
So anyways, I ended up getting picked up
and I had nowhere to go.
My mom and dad picked me
up and my son was at home
with my grandpa and grandma
and they ended up...
I was so scared because,
I didn't think I was ready.
I felt like, "How am I?
"How can I possibly stay clean now?
Here I am, super upset.
I'm having constant PTSD
episodes every other day.
I can't sleep at night because
I'm waking up screaming,
I'm having nightmares.
I had no clue what to do.
It was just, I honestly thought,
"You're not gonna make it, Ronnie.
"You're not gonna make it.
"Just give up, this is it.
"You tried, oh well, at
least we tried Ronnie,
"you can just keep walking
along, who cares now?"
And I remember when I got in the car
and I told my mom and dad
and I said, "I'm scared."
And they were like, "what do you mean?"
And I said, "I don't know
if I'm gonna make it."
And the place I was gonna go was,
one of my friends and he
was a very good friend,
we've been friends since high school
and him and I had both gone
through addiction together
and he was clean now and
he owns his apartment
and he had a job, he was doing good.
Now, the problem with staying there was,
it was about a 20 minute walk
from the apartment to my drug dealer
This is like the worst position
I could put myself into.
That's like me asking to just
be tormented every single day
that I wake up.
And I just told my mom, I
said, "I can't go there, mom.
"I can't go there", and she said,
"What do you mean you can't go there?
"I thought you said it was a good place,
"I thought you said he was clean,
"I thought you said he was...
"Everything was good,
there was no drugs there".
And I said, "Yeah, there's no drugs there,
"but there's drugs 20
minutes down the street".
And she ended up making
some phone calls and finding
a friend that I could stay with again
until I got into rehab.
And I ended up doing that.
And, I've steady waiting on
court, steady waiting on court
for my CPS so that I can go to,
I can get my son back
and I can live back at
home with my parents
till I can start working
and get on my feet again.
So I spent every single
day at that rehab at Nexus,
they have a program called
the recovery resources
and you're allowed to go
up to Nexus and hang out
with them every single day,
all day if you want to.
And that's what I did.
I got on five different buses and trains
to get from Granbury to Dallas,
to hang out at this
recovery resource center
just to stay clean.
And everybody was like, why do
you come all the way up here?
It's a two hour drive.
So, imagine having to get
picked up by my father
on his way to work 'cause he
worked in Downtown Fort Worth,
pick me up, drive all the
way to Downtown Fort Worth.
Then me having to walk two miles
to get to the train
station, hop on the train,
go all the way to Dallas,
get off of that train,
walk a little bit to go
onto the other train,
get on that train, go walk a little bit
to get to the bus stop
to go to go all the way
to another bus stop and then
get picked up by another bus
to finally get dropped
off a couple blocks down
in the mean time having to walk
from that last bus stop
all the way to Nexus
just to stay clean.
And the thing is, they say,
"If you can go through all
of these things to get dope,
"you can go through all of
these things to stay clean."
And that's what I did.
I did that daily, every single day.
And the recovery resources, coaches,
they ended up giving me a bus
pass, so I didn't have to pay
to be able to come up here,
'cause it was hard for me
to have to pay the bus fare
and the train fare and
then when I'm hungry,
try and find something to eat.
So they ended up getting
me a little regional fare,
which is buses and trains and other,
I don't remember what the other one was.
And I did that for quite some time.
Now in between that, I am not gonna lie.
I definitely had some weak moments.
And I had relapsed one day
and I called my mom and I said,
"I need you to come get me, I relapsed."
And she came and got me
and they took me back
to the family friends.
And 'cause at this point
I'm still not allowed to live there,
but I finally, finally,
finally got visitation rights.
And I remember when my
lawyer told me like,
"Yeah, you can see your son now."
I'm like, (cheering)
I was so just, "Oh man,
"I missed my son so much."
I definitely believe he is the only reason
that I'm still alive.
If I didn't have him,
I don't think I'd have a reason.
My self esteem,
it has its days now where
it's getting a lot better.
But I have those days where
I struggle with my PTSD
and my bipolar and it's just...
It got to a point where I
didn't remember (mumbles),
I didn't remember when
the last time I showered,
because I have been
wearing the same clothes
for three, four or five days,
which is gross.
But that is what my depression looks like.
It can take a hold of me
and that grip that it has
is so tight that I'm
just, I feel restricted,
I'm stuck and I have no,
I have no willpower to move.
I mean, the only reason I was breathing
is just because I have to, my
body just does it by itself.
If I actually had to
physically like do something
for me to breathe, I wouldn't do it.
Yeah, I would have given up.
I think that when the video came out,
I had no clue that it had even been out.
I had thought about it,
but I never knew what your
channel was or anything.
And that was the day that it happened.
When was it?
See, I think it was Jan, no,
I think I found out in February.
And that is when my mom
texted me and she said,
"Are you ready?"
And I'm like, "Ready?
"For what?"
And she says, "Your YouTube
interview is trending".
And I said, "No, it's not shut up.
"Whatever, what do you
really need to tell me?"
And she sends me the screenshot
of all of these people
that have been sending it to her
'cause she had no idea either.
And all these people were like,
I can get on Facebook and there's my face,
she'd get on Facebook, oh there's my face,
there's my face again, scrolls
up, there's my face again.
And it was like everybody
that I knew had seen it.
Everybody that knew my mom had seen it.
I remember looking at the title
and it's saying heroin addict.
And I was like, "Oh, Oh." (laughing)
I was like, "Wow, that's
a big sucker punch."
But in the beginning it
was crazy because I just,
I thought like the worst,
the absolute worst, that
little voice in my head
that constantly tells
me that I'm not enough,
that people are judging me went haywire.
My thoughts were just like,
I thought it was over, it's done.
Everybody's gonna judge me,
everybody's gonna hate me.
Everybody's gonna have
something to say about me.
And all this negativity
just flooded my entire...
My entire being,
it was filled with nothing but negative,
negative, negative, negative.
And I hadn't even watched the video,
I hadn't even taken the time,
just no, nothing because my...
I was scared.
There was not one positive
thought in my head, not one.
It's like, "How can that even be,
"how is it that there's
not a single good thing
"that I can think or say about myself?
"How is it that, I spend
so much time trying
"to do positive affirmations
and tell myself I love myself
"and tell myself I'm beautiful."
But when I saw all those views
and all those people who were
texting me and messaging me.
I couldn't even comprehend anything.
I ended up not going home for three days,
I didn't talk to anybody for three days,
I didn't respond to anybody, nothing.
I didn't open any messages,
any videos, anything
No calls, nothing.
And the one person that
did help me through
is my friend Chris.
And he had been locked up for
a little over a year or so.
And I hadn't talked to him forever.
So when he was finally out,
I asked him, "Hey, will you
"watch this video and
tell me what you think."
And I said, "I need help
getting through this".
And he did, he watched the
whole video and he said,
"Ronnie, there's nothing bad in there".
He said, "There nothing wrong with it".
He was saying that I was a strong person,
that I was gonna be okay,
this was good.
And after that I finally got the strength
to watch the video.
And when I did,
I just, I can remember smiling.
And I read through some of the comments
and just seeing the
people that I had helped,
seeing the people that were just saying,
they were praying for me
that they knew they didn't know me,
but that they loved me
and they cared for me
and that they hoped, that
if I ever read this comment
to know that I'm strong and,
after that, my whole perspective changed.
I finally realized,
that I am somebody.
That my story and my
past does not define me.
It is something that has
helped me make who I am today.
But it's not...
That's not the only thing I am,
I'm not just a heroin addict.
I'm not just a victim of sexual abuse.
I am not just,
a homeless woman.
I'm somebody, I'm somebody who matters.
I have people that care about me.
I have people that, are looking up to me,
if that's the right word.
There's this one comment that I was seeing
and it said,
I'm 28 hours into heroin withdrawals.
And she said, "After watching this video,
"you really helped me not relapse.
"You really helped me see,
"you helped me stay strong to get
"through another day of withdrawal."
And she said, "Thank you so much."
And that was the one that stuck out a lot.
And then of course, you have the people
who are there like, "She's evil."
And I don't know who it
was, but someone says,
I'm in the porn industry,
I don't know if you
ever saw that comment.
- Is at the social media?
- Yes, and I was just like--
- [Interviewer] 5% of it is nonsense.
- My mom was like the porn industry?
And I was like, "right?"
I remember one day she called
me, she said, "Hey momma,
"so what are you doing?"
I said, "Oh, I'm just making my,
I'm about to make my next
porn video..." (laughing)
So that ended up being
a little funny joke,
but once I saw that,
I just, I can't,
honestly, I can't thank you enough
for helping me to do that,
because that was a lot
of stuff that had been
boiling inside of me.
These are things that had
been just pestering me
on a daily basis that
I've been trying so hard
to just keep out of my head,
these are the things that I
just don't want people to know,
that I think are gonna tarnish me.
And they didn't,
it ended up helping me dust
myself off and stand up.
I now have more motivation to stay clean,
to be there for my son.
I wanna go to school now.
I thought I was gonna be a drug...
A heroin addict for the rest of my life,
which I am, once an
addict, always an addict.
I remember telling my mother,
"I'm never gonna stop using,
"so you're just gonna have to get over it.
"I'm either gonna die
from an OD or something."
I said, "But these drugs are
just gonna end up killing me".
And how in the world
can I say something
like that, to my family?
But now it's like,
I feel like I have a lot more hope.
It was like that little
spotlight that you've helped
put on me, has helped me grow tremendously
and I'm not ashamed of it anymore.
- [Interviewer] I think the secret,
to doing these kinda talks
and putting them on YouTube
for the entire planet to see, right?
Is it allows you to take
full responsibility,
for everything.
And the more open and
honest you are as you were,
and a lot of people I talked to are,
you lay it out.
And all kinds of people are
gonna make negative comments
and some are gonna positive comments,
that are beautiful and compassionate.
But whatever the case,
you're just laying all
your garbage out in the sun
for everyone to look at,
forces you to take a look at it
and take responsibility for it.
And then you can decide to do
differently if you choose to,
you don't have to, you
can go back to using,
you can go back to living
like a rat on the street.
Or you can say, "Wow,
if I choose differently,
"I can end up with a different result.
"I can maybe get back with my
son, I can maybe go to school,
"I can maybe get a job, I can
get a better quality of life."
And you can move forward and do that.
But the only way you're
ever gonna do that,
is by putting it out in the sun
and making everybody look at it.
- [Ronnie] And not
keeping it in the shadow.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
that's right, it has power.
By hiding it, it has power over you.
And by exposing it, it
loses its control over you.
- And yeah, that all of
those things definitely
had a strong hold over me
and they just don't anymore.
- [Interviewer] You
look totally different.
- They just, I'm not...
I don't spend all my time constantly upset
in my room crying by myself.
I don't have as many negative thoughts,
I don't have all,
it's just like all this hurt
that I feel all the time,
hurts a little less.
And each day I feel like I'm
getting a little bit better.
I'm making progress each and every day.
Whether it's just somebody saying,
"Hey Ronnie, what's up?
"Do you wanna hang out?"
And me knowing if I hang out with them,
I'm gonna get high
and just saying, no, you know what?
I'm good.
And going to do something else,
going to swim, going to bowling,
going to, just do whatever.
To get myself away from that,
where I'm now making more friends.
I'm going to a church group
with my mother and other women,
They're all older than me,
I'm the youngest one there,
but they feed a lot into me.
It's crazy 'cause even
my mom and dad see it.
People that have known me
since I was 15, see it.
They see the happiness that I have now,
I have one of my family friends,
I've known her since I was
16 and she was telling me,
you're just glowing.
You're just, you can
tell that you're trying,
you're beautiful and you care more
about the things that matter.
You're putting more effort
into being with your son,
with your family, with the
people that are important
to you that are gonna help me grow.
And I just, I love it, I do.
And don't get me wrong, I have my days
where I just, I hate
everything, I hate myself.
I don't think I'm gonna...
I have that little bad voice again.
It says, "what do you think?
"Who do you think you are?
"What?
"Oh, because you've almost got
2,000,0000 views on YouTube,
"you think you're somebody,
you think people care,
"you think you actually have a chance
"to make a YouTube account now
"and start talking about these things
"that other people don't wanna talk about,
"to start healing."
And sometimes I say, "You're
right, it's just stupid,
"it's a stupid idea."
But those days are less and less and less.
So, on Monday I have court with CPS,
my final court hearing
and I'm looking into this thing
called contemporary conservatorship,
something like that.
And that is where I
temporarily signed my rights
over to my family,
so that I can get myself together.
I'm looking into this
program, it's a year long.
You spend the first 90 days
in a locked down facility treatment
and then after that they
get you an apartment,
fully furnished everything.
And as the year goes on, you get a job,
they help you save money,
you don't pay rent.
They help you get a car,
they help you do all of these things.
And before I would've never ever,
ever, ever, ever wanted to go
to a year long program at all.
It was like a year of rehab.
But I mean, I've spent
more than a year rehabbing,
all of the times I'm going to rehab.
But now I have more motivation.
I have more self love, more
self care than I ever have.
And a lot of it was because of that video.
It's just, it's crazy how...
Because I mean, I knew
that I had done the video
and all of those things,
but once I actually saw it.
It was like a light switch went on.
And I'm super thankful for that.
- [Interviewer] Cool, so nice to hear.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Your
video is the only one,
I have two teenage daughters.
And your video is the only one
that I've asked them to watch.
- Really?
Was it because of the bullying or--
- [Interviewer] It's just everything.
A lot of the stuff you
talked about is stuff
that a lot of people deal with.
Not the heroin addiction,
you could delete that whole part
and your talk is still powerful and great.
And that's the part that
I wanted to listen to,
not the drug part, but
the, all the other stuff,
I thought was super interesting
and I think it's stuff that a
lot of people struggle with,
and go through.
You're still going through it at rehab.
It's like it's pathetic
- Crazy right?
- [Interviewer] That
do that to each other.
- I'm 22 years old.
- People are doing it
on social media.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I see it all the time.
You'll see these hateful comments,
what do they think they're accomplishing?
What they don't understand,
what they're actually doing
is hurting themselves,
more than their target,
but they spread it.
- [Interviewer] I mean
like, I watched a video
and if it's something,
I don't wanna watch,
I just turn it off and
never watch it again.
I wouldn't spend the time
to make a negative comment.
Why do that?
- Watch the whole 46 minutes
and then just to say something (mumbles).
I see that.
- [Interviewer] I don't
understand that, but it goes on.
But the best thing to
do is just ignore it.
- Yeah, and I'm getting not
only just like in the comments,
but people are going out of their way
to find me on social media
and just say, I know you don't know me
but thank you.
Or I think you would
really like this song.
Or I'm not a heroin
addict, but like you said,
take the heroin addiction
part out, but I was bullied,
I do have low self esteem.
There's just so much
that we have in common
and actually seeing that
I helped other people,
just by talking, just by using my voice.
And it was just,
it was crazy, it was amazing.
- [Interviewer] You're an incredible girl.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And
that first talk you did,
was really powerful and
interesting as can be.
I just think that it could be
really helpful to a lot of...
I'm sure it has been,
that's why I support it.
- Yeah, so I'm thinking about
starting my own little blog,
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] You should
do anything like that.
- So I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Turn this
into something bigger.
- Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
- [Interviewer] You're doing
the public speaking, right?
When is that?
- Oh wait, a public speaking?
Oh yes, what's today?
Thursday?
Wednesday?
- Today is Wednesday.
- On Friday night I'm going to do a AA,
which is alcoholics anonymous.
And they asked me yesterday
night if I wanted to speak,
'cause they watch your videos as well
and they just wanna talk to me,
have some questions, ask
and oh, Friday night's
gonna be a busy night.
It's gonna be a very busy meeting.
So I'm nervous because
I've never ever spoke like,
at a meeting before.
- You'll do great.
- Or even just like regular.
- It's the same as this.
- So, just like even regular,
I can't speak 'cause I'm just like,
"Oh my God, I sound so dumb."
But now I've always thought like,
"Oh, that'd be really cool to speak."
To tell your story, to do that.
And I've never ever been asked
to tell my story
at any or AA.
- You have pretty insights
and great things to share.
- Thank you.
So now I was like, "Oh."
And I was like, "I don't know."
And he was like, "You don't
have to tell me right now,
"just tell me by the end of the meeting.
"And I was just like, "Oh."
And then I went over there
and I was like, "Okay, I'm
gonna do it, I got it."
- [Interviewer] I would talk
you into it if you didn't.
- (laughing) So, I'm very excited.
I for sure see a lot of
positive things coming my way.
And it's just, it's a beautiful feeling
because of the destruction and the hurt
and the things that not only
other people have put me
through, but those are things
that I put myself through,
constantly hating myself,
constantly wanting to die,
constantly, just feeling like nothing.
And now it's like,
sometimes even when I have that little,
"Oh, Ronnie, you're not gonna make it.
"Just 'cause a lot of people
are giving you good feedback,
"and all this and that on
YouTube doesn't mean anything.
And it does, it means a lot.
And each day I just gotta keep on pushing
and keep on letting myself
know that I'm worth it,
I have a voice and I'm gonna use it.
So, I'm hoping I'm going to
school to be a counselor.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- So that's--
- [Interviewer] I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I hope
that you come by again.
- [Interviewer] Very well, thank you.
- Thank y'all.
- [Interviewer] I'm so happy for you.
- [Ronnie] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I'm proud of you.
I'm very, very happy--
- [Interviewer] You can
tell, you can feel it,
you can see it and feel it.
- [Ronnie] The difference
between last time.
- [Interviewer] And you
look healthier and better
when you stand up
straighter and everything.
- [Ronnie] I'm not so
anxious like I was last time.